my name is Sunil Ryan I lead Google
cloud for games team here at Google and
it's an honor for me to be here today as
you can imagine and see Google has
announced some really big things this
week so I'm sure many of you attended
mobile developer Day on Monday and if
you haven't you should definitely check
out the Tuesday keynote we announced a
big platform called stadia and today for
the first time we actually have an
entire day dedicated to Google cloud
developers and we've got a fantastic
lineup of speakers both subject matter
experts from Google but more importantly
customers and partners that are going to
talk about how Google cloud is helping
power power day games but before we get
into the detail I want to take a step
back and talk a little bit about the
trends that we're seeing and how it
affects our approach in in Google cloud
you all know there has been an amazing
explosion of players globally about 2
billion which means as huge opportunity
and the industry is growing at a
tremendous rate and this is all thanks
to people like you who are with your
creativity are building fantastic games
so that's one so we're dealing with
massive scale second it's just not about
players right the business of games took
about 35 years to get to 35 billion
dollars in revenue but then in the
subsequent 12 years we've or 11 years
we've added another hundred billion
annually so it's not just there are lots
of players there's a lot of money in
this market and it's kind of becoming
the biggest entertainment industry out
there so so that's number two because we
are seeing ways for people to monetize
number three what we're also seeing is
with the democratization of devices you
have to reach a player base that is of
different sizes and shapes and different
screen sizes and what people are
starting to see is with 5g coming and
low latency in different areas Triple A
games or mobile games are thinking that
you know people are going to be platform
agnostic so you need to start building
for different sizes and shapes and some
some of these things that we talked
about even
yesterday's keynote on stadia that you
can play across different devices lastly
as a trend that we also seeing is a game
is just not a game anymore
you have it's becoming an ecosystem you
have successful games that have more
developers creating content we have
social connections and things can
explode from day one so it's really hard
to forecast what's going to happen and
prepare for it and the second thing is
as a result games our lifetime is
becoming longer and longer because you
have ways to update content so the new
normal pretty much right now is to you
need to constantly develop an iteration
and iterate and that's the new normal
for building games so these are the
trends that we took into account and
said ok how does that affect what the
Google cloud game strategy should be and
how we can help developers and we and
what is and after talking to a lot of
you we also heard this these are the
there are four things that we need
taking the trends into account and what
we heard from you one you want scale
from day one if you want to be
successful you don't want any obstacles
when you launch a game to say oops
I couldn't scale so I'm not gonna be
successful so that's one number two with
all the different devices and with the
different platforms you want flexibility
so you can build once and deploy it in
as many places as you want number three
you also said you know I want less
operational overhead and I just want to
focus on building good games and lastly
given you know you never know what you
can expect in terms of players you want
better ability to predict outcomes you
want better ability and forecast where
players are coming from etc so
predictability is becoming a core need
for a lot of game developers as well so
we took this into account and said you
know what does Google cloud for games
actually stand for so one you will hear
a lot about this from us throughout the
rest of day one we want to enable
cross-platform services and solutions
number two we are committed to open
source you will see in subsequent
sessions that we'll talk a little bit
more about how we are partnering with
the industry to push the thought
leadership forward and we won
to give developers choice number three
we you know Google has been used to
having lots of data and building
analytics predictive algorithms machine
learning is becoming core so you will
see a lot of machine learning services
from Google and lastly if you haven't
seen the commitment I would say for the
first time we have them the number of
Googlers at GDC is exploding and that's
because we have a commitment for games
and what that results in is we want to
bring the best of Google to you across
different product areas and different
solutions and you will hear some of that
later today as well let me dive a little
bit to say this is not just in theory we
actually have top triple-a games and
mobile games running on Google cloud
this is just a sample list of games game
titles as well as partners that we're
working with like multiplayer and unity
and improbable that's helping advance
what cloud can do for your games so
diving a little bit deeper into our
strategy one of the things that we have
committed to is giving developers choice
and a lot of things in Google cloud we
have this platform called kubernetes
which is based on containers and we feel
like that's something that gives choice
because you can run kubernetes on google
cloud on on-premise on your bare metal
as well as on other clouds and we're
just not committed to this in Google
cloud we're committed to that in gaming
in Google cloud as well and some of the
examples that we have partnered with the
industry to push the thinking on is one
we've got a project open source project
called a gonna is that we launched about
a year ago that you'll hear more off
which automatically helps you scale your
game server processes so you don't have
to worry about it and also gives you a
good dashboard of metrics on how
servers are scaling up and down we've
also again with an industry partner with
unity launched open match which is a
matchmaking service it's open source
anybody could take and use it and put in
your specific logic in to make
matchmaking work so we're we're just not
saying open source we are actually doing
specific projects that are related to
games
it's also not just that we are you know
funding these projects we're also making
easy for you to access it and as of
today you can use a go nez with a simple
click from the cloud marketplace and
embed it into your game so this is
something that is very exciting for us
and helps advance kubernetes and Game
Servers into the industry as well the
next part that in our strategy is we
want you to get results fast and get
more player insights because you want to
get you know improve the player
experience as well as get more insight
from your players and we've partnered
with lots of sorry I flipped the slide
you go back one we've also partnered
with a lot of companies big companies
which have you know humongous amounts of
data like 50 petabytes with people like
King and Square Enix to bring more
insights about your players so you can
improve the design of your game or
improve the monetization of your game on
infrastructure we we also partnered very
closely with massive entertainment
studios you're the next slide please
to help launch tom clancy division 2 and
this is we have a model where we are
customer engineers were in the war room
to make sure this launch was successful
this actually launched on Friday last
week so this is a little bit of what we
talked about and last I'll finish on our
strategy we want to bring the best of
Google we want to help the game industry
succeed we want help developers succeed
and we feel Google cloud is the glue to
those efforts and with that we want to
work with different Google teams to
bring this to life and on that note I'm
sure you heard about Stata yesterday and
let me bring up our next speakers who
are going to discuss how stadia and GCP
are and Google cloud platform actually
better together Micah
Thank You Sunil good morning I'm Micah
Baker I'm a product manager for gaming
on Google Google cloud and I'm joined by
my colleague Pavel who is a product
manager on stadia and I'm sure you would
love to hear a little bit more about
that exciting announcement from
yesterday and so I'm gonna hand it over
to Pavel to talk a little bit about
stadia and then I'll talk about how
Google Cloud and stadia work better
together thank you so stadia was
announced yesterday who's singing the
keynote or has heard a little bit about
it okay
fair number so as a quick summary stadia
is a new kind of platform it's it's a
cloud-based gaming platform for triple-a
gaming that is based on streaming and it
is a new platform that lets you build
new kinds of games but we have built it
to be intuitive and work with all kinds
of games and so very we're very excited
about what we can bring to it and what
makes it unique of course is that
because it is hosted on cloud and it's
streams and it can connect to different
devices and different endpoints without
having to change the core game
experience or how you build it we're
launching in 2019 and the reason this is
relevant to this audience specifically
for the for the Google Google cloud is
that whenever your game is running on
stadia it's always running in a
virtualized environment on a specialized
VM that we call in instance and these
these instances connect to the endpoints
through a stream through the internet
and Wi-Fi and ever the player is playing
on but the part that is important to
remember for here is that the stadia
instances aren't generic GCP virtual
machines they are specialized and so you
will interact with them in the stadia
environment now when players are playing
we take care of those instances so once
you launch your game when players are
playing we manage all of that so you
don't have to worry about it
but when you're in development and you
have your developer instances then you
will be interacting with them in our
environment and this is where some of
the power that you see if you can come
in because all of the this data
infrastructure is
the same backbone that the GCP is
running and so the connection to GCP is
very fast and an efficient and do you
talk a little more about that Mike oh
thank you so now that you understand a
little bit of the logistics of stadia
it's interesting to compare how that
fits in with the Google cloud story
Google Cloud has a unique global private
network which is really fundamental in
this better value that we're going to
talk about here so you think about all
these different connections across the
globe and having a private network
really matters when you want to control
latency what does this do to stadia for
example so when you work with Google
Cloud and stadia that private network
actually comes in very handy because we
can have all the traffic local the
traffic never has to go through the
Internet as you may experience through
other clouds what happens if your if
your network traffic has to stay local
down what does that bring to your game
into your experience it really comes
down to these three main points your
traffic is never exposed to the Internet
so no one can mess with your traffic the
game data is gonna be secure you can
count on the performance it's
predictably low latency because it's
always on that private network where we
can control the quality of service it's
also great value because there's no
charge for egressing to the internet
from the cloud so we're really excited
about the combination of stadia and
Google cloud and we look forward to
talking more about this this was just
kind of a little sneak peek into what
we're thinking and next I'm gonna hand
it over to Pavel to talk a little bit
about what you can do to learn more
about stadia thank you so just to finish
off this if you would like to work with
stadia if you have a game idea that
you'd like to bring to our platform then
please head over to stair dev and we'd
love to hear from you and we're taking
these applications now and then we'll be
getting back to you throughout does
of the year and also come see us at our
booths in demos if you actually want to
check out some of some of the tools how
they work we're in West Hall for like
the developer section and the South Hall
has more of the playability sections and
so you can both experience it and see
what it will look like to actually build
on Stadium thank you alright so we're
very excited to continue this
conversation offline if you have any
more questions and next I'd like to
involve invite my friend Paul up from
multi-play where we're gonna talk a
little bit about some of our successes
and working together on scaling their
games
thank you thank you Micah um good
morning everyone my name is Paul Manuel
I'm the managing director of multi play
and thank you to Google for asking us to
come and talk today what I'm gonna be
touching on is essentially what
multiplay did to give you a little bit
of context why we work so closely with
Google and I'm gonna talk about quite an
exciting case study which we worked on
this year ok just to frame it up a
little bit I think it's worth explaining
a little bit about multiplayer and what
we do so we are game server hosting
specialists and believe it or not we've
been doing this for nearly 20 years now
so we have launched a lot of games and I
think I wouldn't say we've seen it all
but we've seen a lot now we don't create
games but we do power them so
effectively that is our calling so a lot
of you in the audience create games and
but our thing is we power them through
infrastructure and and it is our belief
that we have a responsibility to the
game players of the world when they
invest either their money or their
valuable time to get on a game and be
able to play it quickly fast lag free
and likewise we also feel like we have
an obligation to the game developers you
know whether you're a studio of two
people or 200 people if you're going to
invest two or three years of your life
into building the most awesome game then
when it comes to launch day you've got
to make sure you get it right and all
those customers get to play your game
and that's our job so we work hard on
this and we've been working with Google
cloud for probably getting on there for
years now and we'll talk a little bit
more about that just to finish that
story and finish the framing at the tail
in the 2017 multiplayer became part of
the Unity family so we're super proud to
join unity and if you know anything
about unity and you know that they're
the world leading real-time creation
platform and then they build awesome
tools for creating games but what you
may not know is beyond the creation
phase as unity we now move into the
operational phase and this is where
multi placeit's
so we provide the infrastructure for
large online multiplayer games you'll
hear soon more about the multiplayer
matchmaker and we also have vivix who
are similar to multiplayer they've
joined the YouTube unity family recently
who power voice comes for some of the
largest games in the world including
fortnight and pub G and so on so the
operational phase is something that we
do a great deal of the important message
here though is we are engine agnostic so
at multi play we will host games
regardless of what engine it is whether
it's unreal unity or whatever there we
work on those so on to cloud let's talk
about cloud and the impact it has on the
gaming industry well it is true that
cloud is a game changer that's for sure
you can now do stuff that you never used
to be able to do before in the past you
either before cloud existed when you
came to launch a game one of two
scenarios would exist you either had too
much hardware and only this many players
turned up and that's an expensive
situation to be in
or arguably even worse you have this
much hardware not enough and this many
players turn off in which case and we've
all been there that's when you can't get
into the game the most frustrating
situation to be in and it was a very
very difficult problem to solve and if
you had that second scenario then you'd
find yourself scrambling trying to get
more servers in whereas cloud actually
enables us to get rid of that problem
completely I'm just going to talk about
three very typical we've seen many many
shapes of launches but here's a here's a
few examples this is the one we call the
highly anticipated launch okay so this
is the game that everybody knows
everybody knows it's coming it may be
it's a first-person shooter that comes
out just before Christmas every year or
it's a seasonal sports title or
something like that so you know it's
coming or Mabley it's a massively hype
to new IP that everybody's super excited
to hear about and along comes launch day
and that's what the peak looks like and
it looks like this pretty much every
time and that peak is massive
and it lasts for a week or two or maybe
a month or so and then it dies down and
then hopefully what happens is people
stay engaged in the game the people who
love the game and then you invest in and
it grows from there so that's the
anticipated launch next slide we also
see quite a bit of this and we have
games that we host a multi play exactly
like this so this is your games as a
service type model they're seasonal they
will have large DLCs or large events
going on large promotions large
tournaments or they have seasons and
you'll see three or four spikes like
this per year the message to take away
again it's a different shape but what's
consistent is it's very very erratic and
very spiky and you have to have enough
infrastructure to cope with each one of
those spikes accurately every time and
the third example I'll give you and
possibly for me the most exciting one at
all of all is the game that nobody knew
was going to come along and it was a
massive hit so this is the unexpected
hit and we've seen this with pub G we've
seen this with a fortnight and we've
seen it with the likes of Pokemon go
and more recently apex legends and I'll
talk a little bit more about apex in a
minute but what I can tell you is an
extreme version of that very graph
happened with apex legends in the first
week of its launch and this is the tough
one because this is the one when you
literally have no idea how many players
are going to turn up but if a lot turn
up in their Millions
then you need to be absolutely sure you
have the cloud and the infrastructure
and the orchestration layer ready to
scale it to them
okay so onto a little bit of case study
for you as I said we mark with many many
different games we work with rocket
League we work with pub G we work with
tripwire and killing floor but we have a
very special relationship with our
friends at respawn and going back a
couple of years we did the launch of
titanfall 2 and collectively we this is
where we really honed our craft I think
in terms of blending multiple clouds and
bare metal infrastructure into one
single fabric enabling their match make
it just to talk to us via a single API
so they have a game they say we have a
group of players we're ready to go we
need a server on us West multiplayer can
I have it boom and we come back with the
server what happens behind the scenes
they don't need to know about it's magic
to them but as you can imagine it's a
blend of multiple clouds and bare metal
but there's a lot of GCP in there as
well so titanfall 2 was a phenomenal
launch it was flawless there all the
players got to play the game had
incredible reviews super super high
Metacritic rating but the only shame I
guess in some respects is not quite as
many players turned up as everybody had
hoped for however fast forward a couple
years and respawn once again in February
of this year we launched apex the key
difference here of course is this game
was free-to-play what actually happened
is in the first 8 hours we saw a million
players and then the first 72 hours of
three days we saw 10 million players
that we served and within the first 4
weeks we have sold 15 million players on
this game each one of them on the whole
always getting in and having a great
experience in apex legends and how do we
prep for something like that well if you
can see that little video running it's
all about preparation actually it's
about testing this stuff doesn't happen
by magic this is us scaling up GCP in
advance as a test to an enormous number
we picked out of thin air 14 million
players and if you watch the top right
hand corner you'll see that we span up
in the in a period of 90 minutes enough
capacity to serve 14 million concurrent
players in a game
we weren't expecting that amount of
numbers but we tested it in advance
anyway and what we were testing here is
not just GC Peas ability to scale at the
pace that we needed it to we're testing
our own core infrastructure to ensure
that it could take that volume of
requests in that amount of time which it
did but the real key message to take
away from here is test in advance okay
so as amazing as Google Cloud is or any
cloud and as amazing as our own
orchestration layer is that I love to
talk about you still have a matchmaker
it still needs to work in the right way
it needs to be stressed tested one of
the great things about working with a
studio such as respawn if you've ever
played any of their games you will see
that they are meticulous in everything
they do and I can tell you from
firsthand experience they are meticulous
at their testing as well so test in
advance make sure you're ready work with
a partner so when it comes to that day
having worked for all those years of
building your game you are ready for
launch and things work and players get
in and that can make a break again and I
can tell you when it goes wrong
Twitter lights up because I follow the
term server on Twitter and I know what
it looks like when things go wrong and
Twitter lights up and it will be in the
thousands of people well tell you in the
launch of apex legends Twitter was very
quiet in fact what was wonderful about
it is we saw a whole bunch of tweets
about people saying wow is this game
just launched to this many players with
no server problems and that was a lovely
lovely thing to see so with Apex Legends
we went from zero to hitting over two
million concurrent players in the first
seven days we span up in GCP 6,500 VMs
and these are big VMs by the way these
are these are meeting machines and that
was across 53 locations globally and the
vast majority of the game was in Google
cloud so why do we work so closely with
Google well actually there's a number of
reasons and I've called out four here
pointing back to when we first looked at
cloud we benchmark and we we still to
this day use multiple clouds but we
benchmarked Google and won there were
things that our engineers loved was
actually it was very simple to you
in fact in their words they found they
thought they had the gold standard of
documentation and what it meant is we
had no experience in Google Cloud and
within a very short space of time we
were up and running with very little
help from them in the sense that their
documentation was excellent the other
thing is scale of course Google are
continuing to invest not over in their
phenomenal network but in terms of the
amount of data centers they have around
the world and they continue that
investment today so we get global
coverage performance was the big one
though what we really really cared about
is from making a request to a server how
quickly can we get that server back you
can imagine when you're scaling from
zero to two million concurrent you need
to be sure that you're getting virtuous
back very very quickly with Apex legends
we will get a server back from a cold
request to up run and booted in less
than two minutes
and then we do a little bit of
multiplayer magic on top of that and
then the server is in the pool ready to
be used to be super clear there no
player waits for two minutes so our
algorithms are multiplayer is constantly
tracking the rate of change to ensure
that we have servers up and running and
warm ready to go as soon as the request
comes in so players were in an instance
but yet incredible performance and then
the last one which you rarely hear
people talk about when they talk about
cloud is the people actually so we've
had a phenomenal partnership with Google
from day one
and even when multiplayer was a lot
smaller than what it is today they
really looked after us in terms of
testing stuff doing unusual stuff making
sure everything worked and in the launch
of apex legends again and we were able
to scout a phenomenal phenomenal amounts
of VM ins in a short amount of time and
that's because we had Google cloud
working very very closely with us to
make sure we were well-prepared for this
project so the partnership in terms of
the people is absolutely key so final
kind of wrap-up for me really is I guess
for you guys you know this making games
is a very very difficult thing to do so
it would be great if you just had one
less thing to worry about and for me I
think it's the infrastructure so if
there's one thing you take away from
this talk today is that we know that
creativity is the beating heart of
any game studio but you don't need to
worry about the infrastructure logistics
those problems have been solved by
companies like us many many many many
times over okay and here's a quote from
John sharing from respawn he says for
the launch of apex Legends it was
critical both that we showed the scale
of our servers up we could scale uh
servers up sorry uptown to whatever size
audience showed up and that those
servers were reliable we continued our
partnership with multiplayer to leverage
their multi cloud autoscaler so we can
focus on developer time on the game
itself and not on keeping the game
servers running that's absolutely key
John sharing not just from respawn but
from Call of Duty infinity infinity war
call of duty modern warfare and all
those games these are very experienced
people and they've made the decision
actually let's let someone else look
after the infrastructure we'll
concentrate on the game that's it for me
thank you very much I'm gonna hand back
to Mike
thank you Paul one of the one of my
favorite things about multi-play is the
people technology is great but people
are what make the relationships work and
multiplay excels at relationships so
we're really pleased to work with them I
also wanted to mention that one of the
benefits of using for example
multiplayer or hosting games on GCP in
general along with stadia is that you're
in a perfect position to be
cross-platform so you'll have you'd be
able to host your game servers in one
place and service all the different
screens that you want to get your game
to so it's my pleasure to invite our
next speaker up Rami Ishmael who will be
talking to us about our developers in
global diversity as a as a game
developer you quickly come to realize
that play is a global language it is
something that people understand
regardless of their culture their
language or the heritage if you put a
ball on the ground no matter where in
the world you are and you kick it
towards somebody now you'll find that
they kick it back over the past decade
or so I've traveled around the world to
meet an assist game developers that work
in the widest possible variety of
circumstances from developers that work
in the ice cold north minimum in a month
long night to developers that are making
games on a cliff overlooking the the
plains of Africa and during those
travels I've always aimed to assist
developers with the challenges unique to
their country access to knowledge do you
experience to press funding and to
technology and it has been my career
goal to democratize access to our
technology to our libraries of knowledge
into our industry the further that go a
group of talented games industry members
and myself have formed an have founded
gamed after world which is an online
life streamed multilingual games
conference and as we gather here in San
Francisco it is worth considering the
privilege and opportunity that events
like the Game Developers Conference
offer creators that are at Western or
that speak English or that I at that
economical access to these events so
from June 21st until June 23rd game deaf
that world will livestream for free game
developer talks in 8 major languages of
the world English French Spanish
Brazilian Portuguese Japanese simplified
Chinese Russian and Arabic speakers from
all over the world speaking in their
native tongues will share their
knowledge perspectives and stories for
the first time in the history of the
games industry will be able to share
that knowledge across the language
barrier through live subtitling the
internet was touted as a globally
connected technology a technology that
would allow us to reach beyond our
cities to speak across our borders and
to create for global audiences it has
achieved many of those goals but many
challenges and opportunities remain so
as we advance through 2019 it is
critical to acknowledge that major
technologies don't support non Latin
languages in their software or websites
that global often means everywhere but
Africa and that inclusivity is often a
shortcut for inclusivity for those who
speak English it is important to realize
that through technology diversity and
proactive efforts we can challenge and
defeat many of those notions if only we
consider that the Internet is larger
than the Latin alphabet that access to
high-speed Internet is still not
ubiquitous and that language and access
are some of the largest invisible
privileges all of us in this room share
we've seen the internet connect players
all over the world to play games
together despite not sparing sharing a
language we've seen how global
communities solve problems together
create beautiful content in games
together and play together despite never
meeting the games industry has pioneered
ways is play ways of connectivity that
are unrestrained by language and
Universal in their reach so as I travel
the world to meet the game development
community in emerging territories
sometimes half a dozen creators
sometimes hundreds of them I see how
open-source technology and free tool
sets have democratized our industry I
see how knowledge sharing takes a little
bit of time but affects thousands of
careers and lives across the world
I see how community translation makes
information available in one language
available in another and I've seen our
making issues of axis and X issues of
opportunity more visible through the
internet has enabled our industry to
respond to challenges we would otherwise
be entirely unaware of i've gamed of
that world we think about those truths
as we prepare for the event
we're optimists about the potential of
technology in the world we are optimists
about the role of the Internet as
connective tissue between humans we're
optimists about equalizing opportunity
and access through the networks that
already exist and we believe that
progress is both to dream about what
isn't possible yet and to critically
examine what is available to only a few
of us we have found those same values
and that same enthusiasm and optimism
in the Google cloud team we are next we
are extremely grateful for their support
as a diamond sponsor for game dev dot
world our goal is to even if just for
one moment shatter the language barrier
they show the medium and industry of
games as it truly is a global force a
universal language not constrained by
the language we speak the place we are
born or the access we have as the game
of the world team works towards works to
present the first ever international
games conference we hope that you will
sign up for the conference have game
deaf that world and that you will join
us life on the internet on June 21st
thanks so much